bernard vous rappelle je le dis aux
téléspectateurs bien vous vous aviez
fait une interview à l'été sur tf1 et
vous aviez dézinguer tous les animateurs
de tf1 vous aviez dit arthur sans
prompteur il sait rien faire
oui il ya vous avez dit quoi d'autre
arthur - non il y avait il y avait
surtout arturo j'avais dit que sans
prompteur ne peut pas s'en sortir et
qu'en plus on paye pas le dire vous
situer sur tf1 dont vous aviez dézinguer
tout vos camarades
ouais qu'est ce qui s'est passé racontez
moi comment ça s'est passé dit françois
moi j'ai envie de savoir quand est ce
que vous faites c'est indiana on a tous
envie savoir celle que téléspectateur
mais c'est surtout pourquoi un matin je
lui qui était si gentille avec un joli
charia des gens comment s'effectueront
vous avez décidé comme ça de vous dire
je vais dire ni comme bouc je vais
flinguer tout le monde oui parce que
d'abord je vais vous dire j'avais
beaucoup d'émissions l'époque mae sai on
avait là une et avoue j'avais vidéo
gagne en avoir pour les plus jeunes
voilà alors oui les files et des
primetime 4ème les knicks était brisée
dimanche c'était nicotine voilà
exactement
oui mais bon on ne m'achète pas moi
évidemment je gagnais beaucoup d'argent
je le reconnais mais il se trouve que
mon père de famille avait pas de famille
c'était bidon tout et un bidon c'était
violent le rapport était violent était
totalement méprisable et j'avais proposé
une émission pour me sortir un peu de
l'image de vidéo gag était quand même
très légère même si on faisait je le
rappelle 6,7 millions d'humains dimanche
par dj avec des chiens qui pète
c'était avant l'avènement d'internet ou
maintenant on retrouve ces vidéos
facilement
donc si vous voulez j'en ai eu marre
j'ai proposé une émission sur le cinéma
parce que j'aime ça mais en fait tu peux
des tic toc à l'époque il faisait tic
torino dimanche après midi sur place et
a cartonné 6,7 millions d'espèces je
n'arrive plus et donc si vous voulez au
bout d'un moment c'est pas là on ne
tient pas avec l'argent on me tient
plutôt à l'affectif et il se trouve que
j'ai proposé donc une émission sur le
cinéma tout le monde était d'accord sauf
que on l'a donné à quelqu'un d'autre
alors là je me dis qu'elle prenne pour
un con à l'époque c'était une jeune
fille qui n'y est pour rien tina kieffer
non c'était sophie soulignac
professionnels qui les décès d'accord on
en voit qu'il n'y est pour rien qui est
à ouidah pogba oui alors il apprend sauf
que là du coup je me dis attend la rage
ils m'ont pris pour un con je veux leur
filer plein la gueule alors moi quelle
plaie jean marc morandini qu'à l'époque
et rmc sajoo rare que vous avez fait
c'est ouais cgt jean-marc jeudi
jean-marc tu vas très content si tu me
rend fou et puis surtout tu me poses des
questions que tu veux n'aie pas peur non
alors il inquiète peu à milan donc là
vous arrivé là
donc là vous pose des questions que
pensez-vous d'arthur il a voulu d'ipo
abbatu bertu
gibert tueur on peut pas trop le
critiquer parce que il va pleurer tout
de suite là au 7e au 12e ses septièmes à
la septième avec le lait etienne
mougeotte et le lait est donc
effectivement j'avais c'est qu'ils
savaient pas lire un prompteur et puis
je me suis dit je suis agacé même comme
je te parle de famille a pas de famille
enfin bon bref j'ai tout balancer comme
ça se passe là là cette interview vous
l'avez fait à quelle heure alors je les
fait c'était au retour du festival d'un
festival de la fiction et c'est en
lisant le journal que j'ai vu que mon
émission telle qu'elle a été proposée
quelqu'un d'autre et c'est là que j'ai
appelé mon les fêtes à quelle heure
cette émission je relève le matin
ah oui c'est le matin 8 à 9h progrès oui
le matin sur rmc libye n'était pas
bourré et donc quoi vous avez un appel
de tf1 tout de suite ou pas non non non
c'était curieux bon bordel tous les
journaux l'ont repris évidemment et tout
le monde ravi de taper sur tf1
mais je dois dire on m'a utilisé aussi
pour taper sur tf1 et de toute façon je
savais très bien que c'est énorme ce que
j'avais fait moi je me barre tout de
suite compris la tête et par rapport à
kege c'est l'accord et etienne mougeotte
qui m'appellent bon alors j'aime ou
jacques c'est le grand patron avec en
valeur des femmes tiennent qui
m'appellent et il me dit bon bernard l'a
quand même tu as été fort un bon je te
comprends ouais c'est pas correct que ce
qu'on a fait mais quand même
tu as été un peu forte c'est le les met
une pression pour te dégager gb
dégagement dégagement avenant se voulait
tous pareils de tous parents et moi ce
que je dis je le pense je retire pas dit
bonjour mr dermato biais de te virer
bien très bien
[Rires]
en plus je l'adoré
alors dit moi et donc est alors donc il
me dit s'agit de dire moi mais je m'en
doutais que tu allumes dirait toute
façon c'est normal en revanche attention
j'ai tourné des émissions d'avant sa
vidéo gag
si tu me payes page interdit la
diffusion me dit veut toujours aimable
moins dans ces cas là
la nanon n'y a pas de problème si tu es
d'accord enfin on va traiter ça il
s'attendait pas à ce que tu dises a donc
hérité des monts payer quand même le
mois entier et puis après casse toi et
il n'y a pas à arthur qui a pas plus
pour te mettre un petit coup de pression
je jamais comme personne ne m'a
personnes à rien personnages et aucun
procès parce que j'ai dit des choses
terribles
et alors après alors qu'après alors là
alors là vous quand vous passez d'une
vie très confortable a plus rien du tout
à ce que vous êtes vous étiez est ce
qu'il ya une autre celle qui vous a
appelé personne personne non il y avait
des coups de pression aussi de la part
de cette chaire etienne mougeotte et et
de l'ensemble de la direction à l'époque
je m'appelle donc heureusement j'ai eu
la chance que donc c'est ce passé au
mois de mars avril et j'appelle les
autres groupes pourquoi qui vous
prennent way we go à c'est ce que m'a
dit quelqu'un que j'avais contacté mois
ou deux mois j'ai appelé mais pas tout
de suite parce que je fasse le point
qu'il avait marqué car il est un peu
trouble donc si vous voulez j'ai
commencé à écrire un livre qui servit
télé réalité chez flammarion qui a très
bien marché
ma plus grande surprise je dois dire et
très vite j'ai la chance qu'un homme qui
s'appelle gérald brice viret m'appelle
il était à la tête de thé de télé
monte-carlo cette keynote
quel patron m'a tapé dans la balle 32
canal et 20,1 des boss de canal et qui
m'a dit votre film intéresse vous êtes
quand même très gonflé rencontre ne
connaissait pas et j'ai travaillé pour
tmc et heureusement ça m'a sorti parce
que du coup temps ce n'était pas les
mêmes salaires que des phares à zéro
alors pourquoi les loyers c'est à dire
au moins dix fois moins vingt fois moins
fort
oui ça change tout ouais